ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLOORING
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THIRD ARMS WILL PREPARE THE
CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS A COUPLE CALL THE ROLL.
HURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN
BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII. LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE
TEEN BELLA THERE AS THE
APPROVED WA VOEPEL WALDRON WARD
WEBER WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND OUR
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROLES. THANK
YOU- THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THIS PRAYER WILL BE A PRAYER IN
OUR TRADITIONAL LANGUAGE-
SERRANO YOU HAVE IT THE
LANGUAGE AND WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WE SEE A LOT OF THINGS
GOING ON IN THE WORLD THE WORLD
TODAY. I KNOW HERE IN THE SONG
OF THE SALE OMADA OMADA BOWL
MADA MADA IS THE WORLD IN OUR
LANGUAGE AND YOU'LL HEAR HOPE
ALMOST IDEAL HOBBY AT THEM THAT
MEANS OUR CLAN OF THE PEOPLE
ARE HERE. TOGETHER AND BEING
ABLE TO SING THE SONG IN THIS
CHAMBER. IT HAS. ALWAYS BEEN
HEARTFELT FOR ME BECAUSE THE
EARLIER- LEGISLATURE THE FIRST
LEGISLATURE PUT BOUNTIES OUT ON
THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE AND
REIMBURSE FOR THAT THROUGH THE
STATE LEGISLATURE BUT TODAY
WITH THE DIVERSITY THAT'S IN
HERE TODAY WE'VE SEEN SO MUCH
CHANGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AND IT'S AN HONOR TO
SING THE. SONG HERE ON THE
CHAMBER FLOOR. WALMART UNCLE
PALMER. I'M THIRTIES ALL ALL
PALMER JOHN SOMETHING ALL
PALMER JONES. I'M THIRTIES ALL
ALL FULL ARE GOING THROUGH DEAR
TOM ALL ON OUR POLL NOT ALL
JONES. ALL THIRTIETH PALMERA
FULL MORE GONE THROUGH. CHIEF
OMADA JONES HOME. WALMART OFF
ALMOST ALL JOHN DOWN THIRTY
PALMER OFF WALMART JOHN GOOD
JOHNSON BOWL- THE TIME TURKEY
BEAUMONT ARBITRON. YOUR HOME.
JOHN PALMER PALMER. DON OMAR
OMAR. TOM O'MARA. HOMEOWNER
HOMEOWNER OMADA. ALL OF YOUR
PHONES PHONE NOT A ROLE MODEL
OF YOUR PHONE YOUR PHONE OMADA
OMADA. YOUR PHONE'S. YOUR PHONE.
YOUR LONG BOWMAN FULL MODEL
YOUR IF. BOB DOLE. JONES PALMER.
PHOEBE ARE PART OF THE PLOT OF
THE ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR MEMORABLES WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAND AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLANTS. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY
REDDIT NINETY ON THE OUT OF
OVER PREPARATIONS AND THIS
WALDRON SECONDS OF THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. WHAT THE COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS ON THE
ABSENCES TODAY'S ABSENCES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DOLLY FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ROBERT RIVAS GIPSON BERMAN
MYSELF TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MEMBERS ARE
REQUESTING UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN ITEM TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN TO THE SENATE. AND
MEMBERS PRESERVATIVES ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
RE REFERRING ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX BY THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. MOVING
TO OUR BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE WILL BEGIN WITH THE SECOND
READING CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
OH FIVE. WITH A MINUTES. ALL
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE REPORTS
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND DEEMED
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WILL BEGIN
WITH THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS FORTY THREE AND FORTY
FOUR THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY
FIVE E. C. R. NINETY SIX CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY CURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST RELATIVE
TO CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY ON THE CALIFORNIAN IN
CULTURAL AWARENESS CONFERENCE
SOMEONE AROUND ASSUMING OPENED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
ACR NINETY SIX. WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY.
CELEBRATED THIS YEAR ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FOURTH AND
ALWAYS ON THE FOURTH FRIDAY. OF
SEPTEMBER. AND THE ANNUAL
CALIFORNIAN IN CULTURAL
AWARENESS CONFERENCE AIMED AT
INCREASING AWARENESS OF
CALIFORNIA INDIAN CULTURE. THIS
MARKS THE THIRD YEAR SINCE THE
GOVERNOR HAS FORMALLY APOLOGIZE
FOR THE PAST HISTORIES AND
ATROCITIES AND GENOCIDE
INFLICTED UPON THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN PEOPLE. WE CAN NEVER
UNDO THE WRONGS INFLICTED ON
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE LIVED ON
THIS LAND THAT WE NOW CALL
CALIFORNIA. BUT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO BUILD BRIDGES TELL
THE RUTH ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
PASSED IN BEGIN TO HEAL DEEP
WOUNDS THAT STILL EXISTS IN
INDIAN COUNTRY. IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR NATIVE MERICAN CULTURE AND
HISTORY TO BE CELEBRATED AND
RECOGNIZED. THIS DAY PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EDUCATE THE
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OF THE
VARIOUS CULTURAL HISTORIES AND
GOVERNANCE THAT STILL EXIST
TODAY THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES ON FEDERAL INDIAN
RESERVATIONS IN INDIA
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ACR NINETY
SIX DOLLARS TO EDUCATE AND MOVE
THINGS FORWARD I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE BUT I WILL ASK FIRST AT
THE ROLE BE OPEN FOR CALL
AUTHORS. THANK YOU MYSTERONS.
THIS WALDRON. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO MORE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES IN ANY STATE IN THE
NATION. IN MY DISTRICT ALONE I
HAVE EIGHT FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES EACH ONE IS DIFFERENT
AND UNIQUE. AND IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE AND
REMEMBER AND EDUCATE PEOPLE
ABOUT TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY. AND
ALL THAT MESS THAT MEANS IN THE
ITS IMPORTANCE. AND TODAY WE
RECOGNIZE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN DAY AND I URGE AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
FOR DISCUSSION MISTER RAMOS IS
US OF THAT WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR PLEASE.
REGISTER THAT. ALL MEMBERS WHO
WISH TO BE ADDED AS CO AUTHORS
PLEASE REGISTER. YOU'RE A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY TWO CO AUTHORS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
THOSE OPPOSING ME THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN EACH OR
SEVENTY FOUR CLERK WILL READ
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KITA WEBER
RELATIVE TO HEALTH
MISINFORMATION THOUGHT TO
RECORD WE ARE RECOGNIZED HERE
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
H. I. SEVENTY FOUR SPEAKS TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF CURBING
PUBLIC HEALTH MISINFORMATION
AND THE THREAT THAT IT POSES TO
OUR SOCIETY. WELL HEALTH
MISINFORMATION HAS ALWAYS BEEN
A PROBLEM ADVANCES IN DIGITAL
COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGY NOW
ALLOW IT TO SPREAD AT
UNPRECEDENTED SPEED. SO MUCH SO
THAT IN THE MIDST OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC MISINFORMATION HAS
CAUSED RAMPANT CONFUSION AND
MISTRUST THAT UNDERMINE PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORTS. MISINFORMATION
HAS CAUSED CONFUSION AND
NATIONALLY HAS LED TO MANY
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS DECLINING
COBIT NINETEEN VACCINES
REJECTING PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES RELATING TO MASKING OR
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. AND USING
UNPROVEN TREATMENTS. WITH OVER
FOUR MILLION CONFIRMED CASES
AND OVER SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
CONFIRMED DEATH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS THREAT HAS
PROLONGED THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC ENDANGERING THE SAFETY
AND LIFE AND HEALTH OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IT HAS BECOME SO
PREVALENT IN TODAY'S SOCIETY.
THAT THE UNITED STATES SURGEON
GENERAL HAS ISSUED OFFICIAL
GUIDANCE IN THE MATTER. I
APPLAUD THE RECENT EFFORTS OF
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS LED BY SUPERVISOR
NATHAN FLETCHER WHO INTRODUCED
A SIMILAR RESOLUTION IN MY
COUNTY. THE ONLY WAY TO ADDRESS
HEALTH MISINFORMATION IS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ALL OF US IN
EVERY SECTOR OF SOCIETY HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT. EACH OF
US CAN DO OUR OWN PART TO
CONFRONT MISINFORMATION. BETTER
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES AND THE MASS MEDIA ARE
NEEDED TO CURB THE SPREAD OF
MISINFORMATION THROUGH
DIFFERENT CHANNELS AND LIMIT
THE DISSEMINATION OF FAKE NEWS.
WE SHOULD ALL WANT TO WORK
TOWARDS CREATING A HEALTHIER
INFORMATION ENVIRONMENT. ONE
THAT EMPOWERS US TO A WELL
INFORMED KINDER AND MORE
CONNECTED WORLD. BUT WE MUST
USE THAT POWER TOGETHER. H. R.
SEVENTY FOUR IS A SMALL BUT
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS A
RECOGNITION THAT THE SPREAD OF
HEALTH MIS INFORMATION IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. AND URGES
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
COMMIT TO COMBATING THE SPREAD
OF FALSEHOODS THAT THREATEN THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I LIKE THE FIRST
ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU DR WEBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LA MESA FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD EARLIER THIS WEEK SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WAS THE FIRST-
LOCAL BOARD TO DECLARE-
MISINFORMATION A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS IN THE REALITIES AS WE
HAVE TO GET BACK TO THIS THERE
ARE FACTS FACTS EXIST STILL IN
AS GOVERNMENT IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN FACTS. IN
PEOPLE'S MISGUIDED OPINIONS
THAT THEY FIND UNFORTUNATELY-
ON PLATFORMS AND DIFFERENT
PLACES WE NEED TO GET BACK TO
FAX IN ORDER THAT WE CAN GET
OUT THIS PANDEMIC IN ORDER THAT
WE CAN KEEP OUR CITIZENS SAFE
SO THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LA MESA FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AND I. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ THOUGHT ARAMBULA
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I ALSO WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD. CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATION ARE FIGHTING TO
BATTLES AGAINST THIS VIRUS THE
FIRST IS OF COURSE THE COBRA
NINETEEN VIRUS BUT THANKFULLY
FOR CALIFORNIANS. SCIENTER
ACROSS THE GLOBE HAVE UNITED IN
THEIR EFFORTS TO CREATE AND
DEVELOP A SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
VACCINE. THE SECOND BATTLE OF
COURSE IS THE UNFORTUNATE RISE
AND HELP MISS INFORMATION WHICH
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO.
MADE CLEAR WE MUST ALL WORK TO
ADDRESS THE THREAT TO BOTH
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY.
COLLEAGUES I URGE YOU TO JOIN
US IN SUPPORTING HR SEVENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU DOT ARAMBULA.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM DR WEBER
HAS ASKED THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHOR OF THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
WISHING TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR TO THE ITEM PLEASE
REGISTER. YOUR CO AUTHOR. ALL
MEMBERS WISHING TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR TO THIS ITEM PLEASE
DO SO NOW. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY CO
AUTHORS. WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALTHOUGH SAY NAY THE
EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS I AM
REQUESTING UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN TO TAKE
UP ITEM ONE PC OR ONE OH FIVE
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ADOPTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THEN WE WILL
GO TO ITEM ONE A. C. R. ONE OH
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
THE PURPLE READ. ASSEMBLY
KERMAN SOLUTION ONE OH FIVE BY
SOME HOLDEN AND OTHER
STRUCTURES THREE SISTER STATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH A PROBLEM
SINCE IN THE- HOLDEN RECOGNIZED
FOR OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT ACR
ONE OH FIVE. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE OH
FIVE WILL ESTABLISH A SISTER
STATE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND THE PROVINCE OF
SENEC IN ARMENIA. SENECAS
DESCRIBED BY ARMENIANS AS THE
BACKBONE OF ARMENIA. AS IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO IMPORTING AND
EXPORTING GOODS FROM THE SOUTH.
WHY STRAIGHT FROM SOUTH SO
CRITICAL SINICA'S BORDERED BY
OUR SOCK. UNDER BROWN JOHN IN
IRAN AS AZERBAIJAN AND TURKEY
ARE ENGAGED IN AN ECONOMIC
BLOCKADE OF ARMENIA WITH
AZERBAIJAN BORDER IN THE EAST
AND WEST CERKNICA IS A TRADE
LIFELINE TO ARMENIA FOR ITS
BORDER WITH IRAN. THIS
RESOLUTION REAFFIRMS CALIFORNIA
SOLIDARITY WITH ARMENIA AND THE
ONE MILLION STRONG COMMUNITY OF
CALIFORNIA ARMENIANS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN. AS A
MEMBER MISSOURIAN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I JUST WANTED TO
BRIEFLY. SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE AND FOR
ASKING ME TO JOIN HIM IN THIS
WONDERFUL BECAUSE- OF FOLKS.
WHEN WE WANT TO PROMOTE THE
IDEAS OF DEMOCRACY AND- OF
PROSPERITY THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
WE DON'T DO IT BY FORCING
OTHERS TO DO IT WE DO IT BY
CREATING INCENTIVES. AND
ESTABLISHING RELATIONSHIPS AND
BRIDGES ARE A GREAT WAY OF
ESTABLISHING. THESE INCENTIVES-
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AND
CALIFORNIA IS LEADING THE WAY
AND I'M VERY PROUD TO STAND AS
A CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS THE
ITEM MR HOLD WHICH LIKE THE
FIRST WILL OPEN TO OFFERS I WON
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU THE PURPLE OPEN ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS WISHING TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR PLEASE DO SO NOW.
ALL MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
REGISTERED AS A CO AUTHOR ON
THE RESOLUTION PLEASE DO SO NOW.
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL THERE
ARE SIXTY THREE CO AUTHORS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
THE SENATE ALL THOSE OPPOSING
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
IS RAISE
YOUR RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER BOTH PAPPAS
ESERVER GREED UPON A LIST OF
FLOOR AMENDMENTS TO TAKE UP AS
A BALLOT TO VOTE. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO ALLOW THE HOUSE TO
TAKE A BIG GROUP OF. OBJECTION
THE CLERK WILL READ THE BILLS
WITH. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
CLERK WILL READ THE BILLS WITH
AMENDMENTS AND THEN WE WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE. FOLLOWING
FORTY EIGHT SUITABLE FOR THIRTY
TWO FOLLOWING FIFTY FIVE
CYNICAL SIX NINETY FOUR. FOLLOW
HIM SIXTY FIVE CYNICAL SEVEN
TWELVE FOLLOW HIM SIXTY SIX IN
A ROW SEVEN THIRTY FOUR. FOLLOW
HIM SIXTY NINE SENATE BILL FOUR
NINE PROBLEM SEVENTY TWO
CYNICAL TO THIRTY ONE PROBLEM
SEVENTY FOR SENATE BILL SEVEN
FIFTY THREE. FOLLOW HIM SEVENTY
FIVE CENTER FORTY SEVEN PROBLEM
SEVENTY SEVEN SAID ABOUT EIGHTY
FOUR. FOLLOW HIM SEVENTY EIGHT
SYMBOL TWO OH SIX PRIME SEVENTY
NINE CYNICAL TO TWENTY ONE.
BOTTOM EIGHTY TWO CYNICAL TO
SEVENTY EIGHT FOLLOW THE NINETY
ONE CYNICAL THREE NINETY SIX
FROM THE NINETY FOUR CYNICAL TO
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT. FOLLOWING
THE NINETY EIGHT CYNICAL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT FATHER ONE HUNDRED
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
POINT ONE- TO SENATE BILL FIVE
EIGHTY NINE FATHER ONE OH FIVE
CYNICAL SIX FORTY THREE. FOLLOW
HIM ONE OF NINE SYMBOL SEVEN
FIFTEEN BOTTOM ONE TEN CYNICAL
SEVEN SIXTEEN FROM ONE
SEVENTEEN SYLLABLE IT'LL FIVE
FROM ONE THIRTY SINGLE EIGHTY.
FIVE AND ONE THIRTY TWO SYMBOL
NINETY EIGHT FROM ONE THIRTY
FOUR CYNICAL TO FORTY ONE
FUNDING ONE THIRTY EIGHT SYMBOL
TO EIGHTY SEVEN FROM THE ONE
FORTY SIX IN ABOUT THREE NINE.
FATHER ONE FORTY EIGHT CYNICAL
FOR TWENTY THREE BOTTOM ONE
FORTY NINE SUITABLE FOR THIRTY
THREE BOTTOM ONE FIFTY TWO
SENATE BILL FIVE TWO TWO FIVE
ONE FIFTY SIX DOUBLE FIVE
NINETY SIX FROM ONE FIFTY A
SIMPLE SIX OF SIX. SIX OF SEVEN
FROM ONE SIXTY ONE CYNICAL SIX
TWENTY EIGHT PROBLEM ONCE EVERY
FIVE SYMBOL THIRTY SEVEN FUND
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT SYMBOL. TO
SEVENTY. AND FOLLOW.
MEMBERS
THERE WAS. AN ERROR IN THE LIST
THE- READING PARK WILL RE READ.
THE CORRECTED LAST FIND FORTY
EIGHT SUITABLE FOR THIRTY TWO
FONG SIXTY FIVE CYNICAL SEVEN
TWELVE FROM SIXTY SIX AND A
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR FROM SIXTY
NINE TO DOUBLE FOUR NINE FIVE
SEVENTY TWO CYNICAL TO THIRTY
ONE FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR
SENATE OFFICE OF FIFTY THREE
POINT SEVENTY FIVE SENATE-
FORTY SEVEN FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
SAID ABOUT EIGHTY FOUR FROM
SEVENTY EIGHT CYNICAL TOOL SIX
BOTTOM SEVENTY NINE TO DOUBLE
TO TWENTY ONE FIVE EIGHTY TWO
SYMBOL TO SEVENTY EIGHT FATHER
NINETY FOUR SYMBOL FOR TWENTY
EIGHT FROM ONE HUNDRED SENATE
BILL FIVE SIXTY SEVEN. FONG ONE
OF TWO SINGLE FIVE EIGHTY NINE
FATHER ONE OF FIVE CYNICAL SIX
FORTY THREE BOTTOM ONE TENDS TO
THE BILL SEVEN SIXTEEN FROM ONE
SEVENTEEN SYLLABLE IT'LL FIVE
FROM ONE THIRTY SINGLE EIGHTY
FIVE AND ONE THIRTY TWO CYNICAL
NINETY EIGHT FIVE ONE THIRTY
FOUR CYNICAL FOR TWO FORTY ONE
FATHER ONE THIRTY EIGHT SYMBOL
TO EIGHTY SEVEN FROM ONE FORTY
SIX SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY
NINE BOTTOM ONE FORTY NINE
SUITABLE FOR THIRTY THREE FROM
ONE FIFTY TO SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY TWO FROM ONE FIFTY SIX
AND A BILL FIVE NINETY SIX.
BOTTOM ONE FIFTY EIGHT SYMBOL
SIX OF SEVEN FROM ONE SIXTY ONE
CYNICAL SIX TWENTY EIGHT FROM
ONE SEVENTY FIVE SYMBOL THIRTY
SEVEN FIVE TO ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
SYMBOL TO SEVENTY AND FATHER
ONCE OF THE NINTH. AT ABOUT A.
HUNDRED THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS
IS FOR THE BATCH VOTE. ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE AMENDMENT
PLEASE STAY ONLINE. ALL THOSE
OPPOSED PLEASE SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THAT AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED. THE BILLS ARE OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I AM RE
REFERRING ITEM ONE THIRTY S. SB
EIGHTY TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WILL BE WE
WILL BE MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SB TWO PURPLE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO BY SOONER
BRADFORD AND OTHERS IMMACULATE
IN THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT DR
WEBER YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE TO
PRESENT SB TWO THE KENNETH ROSS
JUNIOR POLICE DECERTIFICATION
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR BRADFORD I'M
PRO TEM. ACAN THIS BILL WAS
NAMED AFTER KENNETH ROSS JUNIOR
A CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR
BRADFORD WHO WAS SHOT AND
KILLED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AT
RALLY PARK IN GARDENA IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. HE WAS TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD HE WAS UNARMED. HE
WAS EXPERIENCING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. AND HE WAS SHOT
IN THE BACK AND KILLED IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT. KENNETH ROTH WAS SHOT
AND KILLED. BY AN OFFICER WHO
HAD BEEN ENGAGED IN MULTIPLE
SHOOTINGS IN A DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT. HE MIGHT NOT HAVE
BEEN AN OFFICER IF WE HAD A
DECERTIFICATION SYSTEM IN PLACE
THAT HOLD OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE
TO APPROPRIATE STATEWIDE
STANDARDS. UNFORTUNATELY
KENNETH'S DEATH IS NOT UNIQUE.
IT IS REFLECTIVE OF A PROBLEM
THAT PERVADES OUR STATE AND
COUNTRY AS A WHOLE. THERE ARE
PROBLEMATIC OFFICERS THAT
COMMIT MISCONDUCT IN ONE
DEPARTMENT. AND ARE EITHER NOT
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND CONTINUE
TO BE A PROBLEM FOR THAT
DEPARTMENT AND COMMUNITY WHERE
THEY ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE BUT
ARE ABLE TO FIND EMPLOYMENT IN
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT AND OUR
STATE. HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE ONLY ONE OF FOUR STATES.
THAT DOES NOT HAVE A
DECERTIFICATION SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIANS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
JUSTICE ADVOCATE AND POLICE
THEMSELVES ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE CERTIFICATION SYSTEM IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED. SB TWO IS A
THOUGHTFUL WELL MEANING
APPROACH TO THIS ISSUE THAT
AFFORDS AMPLE DUE PROCESS FOR
OFFICERS. FIVE NECESSARY
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION AND
ENSURES THAT GOOD OFFICERS ARE
NOT DECERTIFIED. THIS BILL
CREATES A STATE WIDE PROCESS TO
REVOKE THE CERTIFICATION OF AN
OFFICER AFTER COMMITTING A
SERIOUS A SERIES OF CRIMES OR
TERMINATION FROM EMPLOYMENT DUE
TO MISCONDUCT. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL ALLOWS. THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. ALSO
KNOWN AS POST. A COMMISSION
THAT IS PRIMARILY MADE UP OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
INVESTIGATE GROUNDS FOR OFFICER
MISCONDUCT. SB TWO ALSO CREATES
AN ADVISORY BOARD WITH IN POST
THAT WOULD MAKE INITIAL
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHETHER POST
SHOULD DECERTIFY AN OFFICER.
FINALLY THIS BILL ALLOWS THE
COMMISSION TO DEFINE. BY
REGULATION THE SPECIFIC GROUNDS
OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT THAT
WOULD BE CONSIDERED FOR
DECERTIFICATION. ULTIMATELY THE
COMMISSION HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
DEFINE WHAT EXACTLY IS KIND IT
CAN LEAD TO DESERTIFICATION.
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT BILL. BUT
THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN A NUMBER
OF AMENDMENTS IN RESPONSE TO
MANY OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPONENTS. PREVIOUSLY THE
ADVISORY BOARD INCLUDED TWO
PUBLIC MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF POLICE MISCONDUCT OR
WHO ARE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO HAVE
SUFFERED PLEASE MAKE CONTACT.
NOW THOSE TWO SEATS ARE
GENERALLY FOR NOT ENFORCEMENT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WITH
STRONG CONSIDERATION GIVEN TO
WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN IMPACTED
BY POLICE VIOLENCE. PREVIOUSLY
POST COMMISSION IT'D MAJORITY
VOTE TO APPROVE DECERTIFICATION.
NOW POST COMMISSION NEEDS A TWO
THIRDS VOTE IN ORDER TO
DECERTIFY SOMEONE AND WE ALL
KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO GET
A TWO THIRDS VOTE IN THIS HOUSE.
PREVIOUSLY THE BILL WAS SILENT
ON PRIOR CLAIMS OF ADJUDICATION.
NOW THE BILL EXPLICITLY STATES
THAT NOTHING IN THE BILL
CHANGES EXISTING LAW ABOUT
COLLATERAL ESTOPPEL. PREVIOUSLY
POSED MUSTY CERTIFYING OFFICER
WHO HAD COMMITTED SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT. NOW POST HAS THE
OPTION OF DECERTIFYING THE
SPENDING CERTIFICATION OR
IMPOSING NO SANCTIONS AT ALL
FOR OFFICERS WHO COMMITTED
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT. POST HAS
THE OPTION TO SUSPEND AN
OFFICER OR IMPOSE NO SANCTION
AT ALL EVEN IF THE ADVISORY
BOARD RECOMMENDS
DECERTIFICATION. I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW THAT THERE IS CURRENTLY
A TECHNICAL ERROR BY
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL REGARDING
ONE OF THE AMENDMENT IN THIS
BILL. THE AMENDMENT CLARIFYING
THAT EXISTING LAW OF COLLATERAL
ESTOPPEL APPLIES. TO THIS BILL
WAS PLACED IN THE WRONG SECTION
BUT IT WILL BE CORRECTED IN A
DIFFERENT BILL IN THE COMING
DAYS. SO IN CONCLUSION SB TWO
CREATES ONE OF THE STRONGEST
DECERTIFICATION SYSTEMS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. WITH MORE DUE
PROCESS. FOR OFFICERS AND
CIVILIAN REPRESENTATION AND PUT.
AT EVERY STAGE IN THIS PROCESS.
THERE IS LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPRESENTATION. IN FACT THE
PREDOMINANT SOURCE OF INPUT FOR
THE ENTIRE PROCESS IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT INCLUDING POST
COMMISSION. THE ROLE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT TO SERVE NOT
ONLY TO SERVE BUT PROTECT.
PROTECT THE CITIZENS PROTECT
THE INTEGRITY OF THE BATCH AND
PROTECT LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THIS
IS NOT AN ANTI POLICE BILL.
THIS IS AN ACCOUNTABILITY BAIL.
WITHOUT ANY ACCOUNTABILITY WE
LOSE INTEGRITY OF THE BAD AND
THE BOND WITH THE COMMUNITY IS
BROKEN. A BROKEN BOND AND
DISCUSSED CAN LEAD TO THE
EVENTS THAT WE HAVE SEEN ALL
OVER THIS COUNTRY AND EVEN IN
OUR STATE. WHETHER IT WAS
BERGESEN HERE IN SACRAMENTO LOS
ANGELES OR EVEN IN MY CITY OF
LA MESA. TYPICALLY WE SAY IF
CALIFORNIA GOES SO DOES THE
REST OF THE NATION. YEAH WE ARE
SO FAR BEHIND IN THIS ISSUE OF
DECERTIFICATION THAT WE NEED TO
CATCH UP TO THE FORTY SIX OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE PROCESSES IN
ALREADY TODAY. THE LET'S
RESTORE THE CONFIDENCE SOME OF
OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE LOST AND
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE ONE OF
THE MOST RESPECTED PROFESSIONS
IN THE COUNTRY. LET'S GUARANTEE
THAT ANY INDIVIDUAL GIVEN A
BADGE A GUN. AND THE INCREDIBLE
POWER IS PROPERLY HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE WEEDING OUT THOSE UNFIT FOR
THIS JOB. THE TIME IS NOW TO
CREATE POLICE THE CERTIFICATION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA IT MUST BE
STRONG AND TRUSTED BY OUR
COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR WEBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. MISTER SPEAKER SB
TWO IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING
THAT WE PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
FROM OFFICERS WHO COMMIT AGREES
MISCONDUCT AND CREATE GREATER
TRUST OF LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
THOSE WHO ABIDE BY THEIR OATH
OF SERVICE. LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARGUES THAT OF THEIR AGENCY
DIDN'T FIRE THEM FOR SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT IMPOSED SHOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO TAKE ANY ACTION.
THEY SAY THIS EXPOSES THEM TO
DOUBLE JEOPARDY. HOWEVER THIS
IS NOT WHAT DOUBLE JEOPARDY IS
A AS A FORMER PUBLIC DEFENDER I
CAN ASSURE YOU. DOUBLE JEOPARDY
MEANS BEING PROSECUTED TWICE
FOR THE SAME PROSECUTOR FOR THE
EXACT SAME CRIME ONCE A
PROSPEROUS PROSECUTED ONCE THE
RESULTS ARE BINDING THEY CANNOT
TRY AGAIN IN HOPES OF A
DIFFERENT RESULT. THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY DIFFERENT. POST
BRINGING DECERTIFICATION
PROCEEDINGS IS NOT THE SAME AS
EMPLOYING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES BRINGING DISCIPLINE.
AS AN ATTORNEY. I CAN BE
INVESTIGATED M. DISBARRED BY
THE STATE BAR EVEN IF MY
EMPLOYER DOES NOT FIRE ME THIS
APPLIES NOT ONLY TO ATTORNEY
TURNS WORKING PRIVATE FIRMS BUT
FOR THOSE WHO WORK FOR
GOVERNMENT OR STATE AGENCIES.
SAME GOES FOR OTHER LICENSED
PROFESSIONS THINK ABOUT A
DOCTOR'S CAN LOSE THEIR
LICENSES EVEN IF THEY'RE STILL
EMPLOYED. THE CALIBER CALIBER
WOULD BE THE KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY IS HOW WE ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO VIOLATE
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS STOP
HARMING THE PUBLIC EVEN IF
THEIR EMPLOYER HAS DECIDED TO
OVERLOOK THEIR BEHAVIOR
ESPECIALLY. IF THEIR JOB IS TO
PROTECT AND SERVE THE PUBLIC.
NEVERTHELESS THE AUTHOR AS
INDICATED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO HAS TAKEN AMENDMENTS
TO FURTHER CLARIFY THIS ISSUE.
ONE OFFICER COMMITS EXCESSIVE
USE OF FORCE SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
FABRICATING EVIDENCE IT SHOULD
WARRANT A FAIR AND TRANSPARENT
PROCESS BY POSTERS CHARMAN IF
THAT OFFICER IS WORTHY OF
HOLDING THAT BATCH. THE PUBLIC
IS LOSING TRUST IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT SB TWO IS A MEANS
TO NOT ONLY HOLD. OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
BUT ALSO NECESSARY IF YOU WANT
TO INSTILL PUBLIC TRUST IN A
LAW ENFORCEMENT. WE CAN TAKE A
CRUCIAL STEP TO BRINGING
CALIFORNIA'S POLICING LAWS IN
LINE WITH THE LONG STANDING.
NATIONAL STANDARD RESPECTFULLY
ASK RELIABLE ON SB TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES. MY HEART IS A
LITTLE BIT HEAVY THIS MORNING
SOMETHING ABOUT ALLIES MCLEAN
IN MATAMATA AUBREY ABOUT TO
MERE. WITH QUAN MCDONALD
THEY'LL FORD WHAT HE SHE WILL
SEND FREDDIE GRAY SANDRA BLAND.
AND KENNETH ROSS JUNE. AND MANY
MANY MORE AS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO THE
WINDS OF CHANGE BLOW FROM THE
WEST. TO THE EAST. YEAH WE ARE
ONE OF ONLY FOUR STATES. THAT
DOES NOT HAVE A DECERTIFICATION
PROCESS FOR MISCONDUCT. MY
HEART WAS BROKEN LAST YEAR THAT
THIS BILL COULDN'T MOVE TO THIS
BODY IN THE SAME YEAR THAT
MILLIONS MORE PEOPLE PROTESTED
IN ANY POINT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY AND WE COULDN'T MOVE
THIS BILL. THE STAIN ON HIS
BODY IT'S A STAIN THAT WE CAN
LIVE TODAY. WE ALL RAN TO DO
THE BEST THING THAT WE CAN FOR
COMMUNITIES FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD A MODEL FOR
THIS NATION. WE'RE BEHIND WE
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO SEND
THIS BILL TO THE GOVERNOR I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AYE VOTE
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU MISTER
BRYANT SOME OF OUR CAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO IN MARCH JUST
BLOCKS FOR MY DISTRICT OFFICE
TYRELL WILSON WAS SHOT AND
KILLED IN BROAD DAYLIGHT AT A
BUSY INTERSECTION. HE WAS A
PROMISING FOOTBALL PLAYER WHO
GOT INTO A CAR ACCIDENT AND
ENDED DESTROYED HIS FUTURE HE
WAS THEN LIVING ON HOUSING MY
DISTRICT AND HE WAS SHOT AND
KILLED. BY A POLICE OFFICER
MONTHS LATER. HE WAS IN MONTHS
MAYBE EVEN WEEKS WEEKS LATER
THAT'S OFFICER WAS CHARGED IN
THE KILLING OF ANOTHER MAN. WHO
WAS KILLED IN THAT SAME CITY.
MR ARBOLEDA WHO WAS ALSO
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL ILLNESS
BY THE SAME POLICE OFFICER A
YEAR BEFORE AND I WANTED TO SET
UP AN ECHO WHAT OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO HAS SAID. THIS
HAS TOUCHED EACH AND EVERYONE
OF US NO MATTER WHAT YOUR
DISTRICT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
SEEN OFFICERS WHO DON'T DESERVE
TO WEAR THE BADGE CONTINUE ON
THE BEAT. AND THERE ARE
INCIDENTS WHERE THEN WE SEE
LIFE TAKEN AGAIN. AND IF WE CAN
SAVE THOSE LIVES MEMBERS WE
MUST. THAT IS THE OBLIGATION
THAT WE HAVE ONE OF MANY. AND
SO TODAY I ASK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU TO DO THIS WE
WORKED HARD ON THIS BILL. AND
WE MADE SURE THAT DUE PROCESS
IS INTACT. BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THOSE THAT
CARRY THE BAGGAGE DO IT WITH
HONOR IN THAT WE HAVE TRUST
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THOSE. THAT HAVE ALREADY
KILLED. THEY WILL BE CHARGED
WITH A CRIME FOR THAT KILLING
ARE NO LONGER ON THE STREETS
WEARING THE BADGING CARRYING
THAT GUN. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THEY MAY KILL AGAIN. AND SO
WITH THAT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND
I ASK THE TODAY. WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE NOT ONE OF JUST
FOUR STATES THAT HAVE TAKEN THE
STEP THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
OUR CANS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SARATOGA RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. SADLY I HAVE TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
PARTICULAR VERSION OF SB TWO.
WHILE THERE IS BIPARTISAN
AGREEMENT AN AGREEMENT AMONG
SOCIAL JUSTICE GROUPS LAW
ENFORCEMENT EMPLOYERS AND EVEN
THE REPRESENTATIVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT EMPLOYEES. THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD JOIN THE
OTHER FORTY SIX STATES. AND BY
HAVING A STATUTORY MECHANISM TO
SUSPEND OR DECERTIFY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FOR
MISCONDUCT. BY THAT FALL SHORT
A FELONY CONVICTION. I WOULD
SUPPORT A BILL TO DO THAT AS
LONG AS IT CONTAINED REASONABLE
STANDARDS AND FAIR PROCEDURES
UNFORTUNATELY. ALTHOUGH RECENT
AMENDMENTS HAVE IMPROVED THIS
BILL SOMEWHAT SB TWO IS NOT THE
BILL. I HAVE THREE MAJOR
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL. FIRST
IS THE COMPOSITION OF THE NINE
MEMBER PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS
ACCOUNTABILITY ADVISORY BOARD.
IT IS GROSSLY UNFAIR. IT
INCLUDES ONLY TWO
REPRESENTATIVES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEITHER OF THEM
REPRESENTING RANK AND FILE
OFFICERS. SIX OR SEVEN OF THE
OTHERS CAN BE. ARE VERY HOSTILE
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THIS
CREATES A BIAS. THE REASON
AMENDMENT PROVIDING THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS ONLY REQUIRED TO
GIVE STRONG CONSIDERATION TO
APPOINTING TO MEMBERS WHO HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT TO RUN FULL USE OF
FORCE LIKELY THE CAUSE DEATH OR
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY BY POLICE
OFFICER OR WHO ARE SURVIVING
FAMILY MEMBERS OF A PERSON
KILLED. BY THE WRONGFUL USE OF
DEADLY FORCE BY POLICE OFFICERS
IS SMALL COMFORT. THE TRUTH IS
OF THE BOARDS THAT WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT DOCTORS AND
LAWYERS. THEIR BOARDS DON'T
HAVE PEOPLE. THAT WE'RE BEEN
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY A BAD
SURGERY. OR BAD REPRESENTATION
THEY HAVE LAWYERS THEY HAVE
PROFESSIONALS THAT KNOW WHAT
THAT JOB IS. AND THIS DOES NOT
DO THAT. NONE OF THE OTHER
FORTY SIX STATES HAVE A SIMILAR
COMPOSITION FOR THEIR OVERSIGHT
BOARDS AND MAKE THIS
DECERTIFICATION DETERMINATION.
SOME STATES HAVE BOARDS THAT DO
NOT HAVE A MAJORITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BUT NONE
OF THEM. ARE THIS LOPSIDED. FOR
EXAMPLE MASSACHUSETTS WHICH IS
HARDLY A BASTION OF
CONSERVATIVE IT'S OF THE STATE.
BUT- IT ADOPTED IN YOUR SEARCH
DECERTIFICATION LAW LAST YEAR.
THERE BOARD INCLUDE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL A RANK AND
FILE OFFICER TO OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THE SOCIAL
WORKER A RETIRED JUDGE AN
ATTORNEY APPOINTED BY THE CIVIL
RIGHTS SECTION OF MASSACHUSETTS
BAR AND THREE PUBLIC MEMBERS
APPOINTED JOINTLY. BY THE
GOVERNOR THIS IS A MUCH FAIRER
COMPOSITION THAN THE ONE
PROPOSED IN SB TWO. THE OTHER
ISSUE I HAD WITH IT IS THE BIG.
DESCRIPTION OF MANY OF THE NON
FELONY- TYPE OF OFFENSES THAT
AN OFFICER CAN BE ACCUSED OF-
ANYONE OF US IN OUR WERE IN
THIS ROOM. HAS HAS HAD
STATEMENT THAT THEY'VE MADE
THAT OTHER PEOPLE MISCONSTRUE
IN TURN INTO SOMETHING THAT
ISN'T. IF YOU THOSE TO. S. TWO.
IS A COME SO BILL BUT IN A
CURRENT. FORM IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO IT. SO SHOULD THE OTHER
FORTY SIX STATES AND HAVING A
DECERTIFICATION BILL BUT WE
SHOULD ALSO USE THOSE BILLS
THAT ARE IN THE OTHER FORTY SIX
STATES. COMPOSE THIS ONE SO
THAT IT IS FAIR THAT IT IS NOT
BIASED. AND I THINK ANYBODY WHO
IS WHAT WE HAVE SEVERAL OF OUR
PUBLIC DEFENDERS IN HERE YOU
WOULD NEVER PUT A BIASED PERSON
ON A JURY. AND THIS IS THE SAME
THING. SO MAKE THAT THING LESS
BIASED AND WE'VE GOT US A BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
SADDAM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU A SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS- THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT BILL FOR ME AND I SEE
THAT WHITES NEEDED. ALL THE
STORIES WE SEE OUT THERE NOT
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
THROUGHOUT OUR NATION OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED. IN REGARDS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE USE OF FORCE
I KNOW WE HAD A BILL A FEW
YEARS AGO REGARDING USE OF
FORCE NOT BILLS ALSO DIFFICULT
FOR ME AS WELL. R. AS REMOVING
THE PROCESS ALONG WITH THE
CERTIFICATION WHAT'S IN FRONT
OF US TODAY IS CHALLENGING FOR
ME I KNOW I WANT TO THANK OFFER
FOR. HIS WORK IT AND GETTING IT
TO A BETTER PLACE BUT STILL I
THINK THERE'S MORE. OF WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE OF THE
BILL I THINK THAT ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUE SPOKE TO THE MAKEUP
OF THE BOARD. OF ONE OF THE
CONCERNS I'M HAVING TO IS YOUR
GOING BACK THIRTY YEARS AND
THEN OFFICERS CAREER SOUNDS
LIKE. AND THAT'S KIND OF
DISTURBING TO ME AS WE LOOK AT.
OTHER BILLS WE TALK ABOUT.
TODAY AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
EXPUNGING PEOPLE'S RECORDS OF
WHAT THEY'VE DONE IN THE PAST
BUT HERE WOULD LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE STILL HAVE TO KEEP THAT IN
WHAT THEY DID THIRTY YEARS AGO-
YES WE GOTTA GET THESE ABOUT
OFFICERS OFF THE STREETS OUT OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND YOU KNOW
IT'S TOUGH WHEN I THINK WE NEED
MORE. OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES CONCERNED
TO GET MAKE SURE THE BILLS AT A
BETTER PLACE WE'RE HEARING ALL
THE STORIES ABOUT THE BALLOT
OFFICERS. WELL THE STAFF AT
THIS DIFFICULT FOR ME BECAUSE I
THINK SOME OF YOU KNOW THAT I'M
A PARENT OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER MY SON IS L. A. COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS. AND IT'S TOUGH
FOR HIM YOU KNOW HE'S BEEN ON
THE DEPARTMENT ALMOST EIGHT OR
NINE YEARS. AND HE'S NOT A
MURDER HE'S NOT A RACIST. HE'S
A GOOD PERSON THIS UP TO DO THE
JOB PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
OVER RUNNING AWAY FROM THE
ANGER THE EVIL IN THIS WORLD
HE'S RUNNING TOWARDS IT TO
PROTECT US AND GUIDE US. AND I
SEE IT IN HIS EYES NOW FROM
TIME TO TIME ASSUME. IT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES FOR ME
IS. WHEN I'M WITH THEM OVER THE
WEEKENDS A TIME BEFORE I COME
BACK UP HERE TO SACRAMENTO. I
HOPE THAT ISN'T THE LAST TIME I
SEE MY SON. AND YOU KNOW WHY
BECAUSE WE DO SOME LEGISLATION.
TO FIX THINGS I THINK WE MIGHT
GET WORSE FOR OFFICERS BECAUSE
NOW. THEY HAD DURING THE
TRANSFER GOING TO SECOND GUESS
THEMSELVES. SHOULD I STOP THAT
PERSON SHOULD I NOT ARREST THIS
PERSON BECAUSE IF I DO I'M
GOING TO BE CONSIDERED A
RACIST. BUT TAKE OUT MY GOD WHY
DON'T TO COME AGAIN BECAUSE ALL
THIS GUY'S GOING TO KILL ME
BECAUSE I'M BLACK OR BROWN. NOW
MY SON'S LIKE. BECAUSE OF THAT
I JUST HOPE THAT HE DOESN'T DIE
IN THE LINE OF DUTY AS HE MAY
HAVE SECOND GUESSED HIMSELF.
BECAUSE HE DON'T WANT TO BE
LABELED THAT MURDER OR THAT
RACES. BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT THAT'S PUT ON
THEM. THE FEELS LIKE MAYBE WE
ARE ANTI POLICE EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE NOT. BUT THE IN
IMPRESSION OUT THERE ON THE
STREET FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
THAT MAYBE WE ARE. ARE HERE TO
MY SON I SEE IT IN HIS EYES AT
TIMES I'VE BEEN WITH THEM.
BEFORE HE GOES TO WORK THEN I
CAN KIND OF SEE THAT WARRANTS
CONCERN ABOUT AS YOU LEAVES
BECAUSE- I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S
GOING TO COME HOME. HE PUTS THE
BALLOT JOHN HE PUTS THE BEST ON
PROTECT HIMSELF IN THE
COMMUNITY. BUT IT'S REALLY
CHALLENGING THIS DIFFICULT SO I
WAS REMOVED ALONG WITH THESE
BILLS AND OTHERS I JUST HOPE
THAT WE LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE
BOTH SIDES OF THE ARGUMENT. IT
REALLY WHAT'S BEST FOR
EVERYBODY NOT JUST ONE SIDED.
SO AT THAT ARE SELF CONCERNS
AND ISSUES AND ALL I CAN HOPE
AND SAY IS THAT WE REALLY LOOK
AT THE BIG PICTURE AS WE DO
LEGISLATION THAT MAKE SURE%
THAT'S FAIR AND EQUITABLE
ACROSS THE BOARD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
YOUR RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. WE'RE LONG
OVERDUE TO PASS MEANINGFUL
POLICE REFORM TOO OFTEN WE SEE
POLICE OFFICERS ESCAPE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE VIOLENCE
THEY COMMIT WHETHER IT BE BY A
GUN CHILL COLD OR MISUSE OF
CALIFORNIA LAW. LET'S BE CLEAR.
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE IS BROKEN THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE RIGHT NOW. IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IF AN
OFFICER MISBEHAVES OR DONE
SOMETHING INAPPROPRIATE THERE'S
INTERNAL AFFAIRS. DOES A POLICE
REVIEW BOARD THERE IS SOMETIMES
IN LA WE HAVE POLICE COMMISSION.
WE HAVE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL WE HAVE DAY CALIFORNIA
CITY ATTORNEY WITH CITY
ATTORNEY D. A GRAND JURIES
ATTORNEY GENERAL. AND SOMETIMES
A FERAL DOJ TO HAS TO INTERCEDE
WHEN WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
BAD OFFICER. WE HAVE ALL OF
THAT. AND WE STILL HERE TALKING
ABOUT IT AND WE STILL NOT
GETTING TO THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM OF ELIMINATING BAD
OFFICERS. WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A LEADER IN MANY OF THESE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS ISSUES
WE'RE STILL ONE OF THE LAST FEW
STATES TO NOT HAVE A
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS IN
PLACE TO REMOVE POLICE
OFFICERS. PEACE OFFICER STATUS
AS A MIXED RESULT IN
MISCONDUCT. ESTABLISHMENT SEEN
SUCH A TIMELY COMMONSENSE LAW
WAS SIGNAL TO CALIFORNIANS THAT
ALL OFFICERS MUST CARRY OUT
THEIR JOB PROPERLY AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE. AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS MAJOR REFORM IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE INSURE. BOTH
ADVOCATES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE ABLE TO COME TOGETHER. AS
CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY I HEAR FROM
BOTH SIDES. BOTH SIDES LET'S BE
VERY CLEAR BOTH SIDES ONE
ELIMINATE BAD OFFICERS. I TO AS
IT AFRICAN AMERICAN FATHER TO
AFRICAN AMERICAN SONS ARE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT THEY GET HOME
EVERY NIGHT. JUST LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE IS CONCERNED THAT HIS
SON GETS HOME EVERY NIGHT.
THAT'S WHY WE SHOULD COME
TOGETHER SAID THAT ALL OF OUR
SON. COULD COME HOME SAFELY
EVERY NIGHT THAT THERE IS NO
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE
CLEAR RULES TO THE SOMEBODY
DISOBEYS THE LAW NO MATTER TO
HAVE A BAD WEATHER NOT THEY
DON'T HAVE A BADGE. THAT THEY
ARE PROSECUTED TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT OF THE LAW. LET'S
REMEMBER THE S. B. TWO WAS
INITIALLY SILENT FOR EXAMPLE ON
A TRAINING FOR ADVISORY BOARD
MEMBERS. AND THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. ENSURED THAT AS A-
AS A MATTER FACT THAT THERE
ARE. BEING ABLE TO BE TRAINED
NOW ALL ADVISORY BOARD MEMBERS
MUST TAKE A FORTY HOUR TRAINING
COURSE. ABOUT THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS INTERNAL AFFAIRS
INVESTIGATION EVIDENTIARY
STANDARDS USE OF FORCE
STANDARDS AND TRAINING AND
LOCAL DISCIPLINARY PROCESSES.
IN OTHER WORDS IT'S NOT JUST A
RANDOM GROUP OF PEOPLE. THE
BROUGHT TOGETHER THEIR TRAIN SO
THEY CAN DO THEIR JOB SO YOU DO
THE BEST JOB POSSIBLE. SO THAT
WE CAN GET TO THE FAIRNESS DO
WE WANT. JUST BE BILL CREATES A
FAIR AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS
THAT IS THE FIRST STEP IN
REBUILDING COMMUNITY TRUST.
ADDRESS B. TWO OFFICES THAT ARE
UNDER INVESTIGATION ARE
ENTITLED TO A FULL. EVIDENTIARY
HEARING. DEMANDING FOR MORE
WOULD BE UNFAIR TO THE VICTIMS
OF POLICE ABUSE LET'S BE CLEAR
THIS BILL HAS ALL THE
PROTECTIONS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEEDS AND FOR
MEMBERS WHO ARE A LITTLE
RETICENT ENOUGH IS ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH IN HERE. TO ENSURE THAT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THAT
DO THE RIGHT THING THEY'RE NOT
PROTECTIONS IN HERE TO ENSURE.
THAT THEY DON'T GET RAILROADED
THEY ARE UNJUSTLY UNFAIRLY
PROSECUTED. IT IS TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN FORTY SIX
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED THEIR OWN
DECERTIFICATION LOS I SUPPORT
SB TWO. AND CREATION OF A STATE
WIDE DECERTIFICATION PROCESS
FOR PEACE OFFICE FOLLOWING THE
CONVICTION OF CERTAIN SERIOUS
CRIMES AMER STOCK MISCONDUCT.
LOOK THIS IS THE BEGINNING.
THIS TO BE VERY BEGINNING. AND
IS NOT THE END OF ROOTING OUT
BAD POLICE OFFICERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY THIRTY SECOND GETTING.
THIS IS THE TIME THAT WE TAKE
ACTION SO WE CAN START THIS
PROCESS TO MAKE IT MORE FAIR
BUT MOST IMPORTANT WE GET THOSE
BAD OFFICERS OFF THE STREET I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER. MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
RISE AS A FORMER CRIMINAL
PROSECUTOR AND- I RISE TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY ABOUT WHY I AM
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. AS
PROSECUTORS WE NEED TO RELY ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO INVESTIGATE
CASES AND FAIRLY ENFORCED LAW.
WE CAN'T DO OUR JOBS IF WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO RELY ON CERTAIN
POLICE OFFICERS WHO WE WORK
WITH CLOSELY AS WITNESSES FOR
INVESTIGATIONS. OFFICERS WITH
THE HISTORY OF MISCONDUCT OR
FALSIFYING RECORDS CAN HAVE
THEIR CREDIBILITY IMPEACHED AT
EVERY TRIAL GOING FORWARD THIS
UNDERMINES POTENTIALLY HUNDREDS
OF TRIALS. I WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM POMONA ABOUT. HIS SON. HIS
HEART FULL PERSPECTIVE. I THINK
WE ARE ALL INCREDIBLY
SYMPATHETIC. ABOUT THAT
PERSPECTIVE. AND WE ALL KNOW.
WITHOUT EVER HAVING MET YOUR
SON WE BELIEVE IN HIS INTEGRITY
WE BELIEVE IN HIS HONOR. AND
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT
OFFICERS WITH THE PROBLEMATIC
BACKGROUNDS HARNISH. THE HONOR
AND THE INTEGRITY. OF THOSE
OFFICERS LIKE YOUR SON. THAT IS
WHY I'M SUPPORTING THIS BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MR CHIU. MR LACKEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THIS IS A
SURPRISE COULD THIS BILL CAME
UP TODAY- BUT IT'S WHERE THEY-
OF DISCUSSION ON THIS IS A VERY
VERY POWERFUL ISSUE. AND ONE
THAT WE NEED TO GET RIGHT. WELL
I WOULD TELL YOU THAT'S MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A- CAREER LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSON IS SPENT
MOST OF MY CAREER BEING IN
SUPERVISION. INTEGRITY TO THE
BADGE IS THE ONLY WAY THAT YOU
HAVE EFFECTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
IT'S ONLY WAY. AND SO DO WE
NEED A CERTIFICATION PROCESS OF
COURSE WE DO. BUT SOMETIMES OUR
MOTION HELPS DEFINE WHAT WE SEE
AS FAIR AND UNFAIR AND I WOULD
ASK YOU TO JUST STEP BACK FROM
YOUR EMOTIONALCOMMITMENT FOR
JUST A MINUTE. AND THAT YOU
CONSIDER. ONE OF THE CONCERNS
I'M JUST GOING TO MENTION ONE
OF THE CONCERNS OF THIS BILL.
IT'S GETTING CLOSE AND I THINK
THERE'S BEEN SOME ATTEMPTS. TO
MOVE TOWARDS FAIRNESS BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S- IT'S WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE AND THIS IS A VERY
VERY POWERFUL MESSAGE TO OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT. VERY POWERFUL
MESSAGE. THAT I THINK HAS BEEN
MISUNDERSTOOD. BY MANY WHO WEAR
THE BADGE WE ALL SUFFER FROM
THAT ALL OF US SOME MORE THAN
OTHERS AND I WOULD SAY. PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT IN THIS ROOM ARE
MORE AFFORDABLE. TOO BAD LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND THAT ALSO
MEANS DISENGAGE ONE FOR SENATE
AND THAT IS A NATURAL RESULT TO
UNFAIR LEGISLATION IS
DISENGAGEMENT. THINK OF IT IF
YOU ARE A BADGE HOW WOULD YOU
FEEL. WELL LET ME JUST TELL YOU.
ONE OF THE CONCERNS I HAVE OVER
SB TWO IN ITS CURRENT STATE IS
THE DEFINITION OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT. OFFENSES FOR WHICH
AN OFFICER MAY BE SUSPENDED FOR
DECERTIFIED BY POST. WE ALL ARE
VAGUELY DESCRIBED WE ALL AGREE
THAT MISCONDUCT SHORT OF A
FELONY CONVICTION SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR DECERTIFICATION
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT BEFORE
WE EXPOSE AN OFFICER TO
POTENTIALLY BEING BANNED. IN
THEIR PROFESSION BUT THE
DEFINITION BE LIMITED TO THOSE
OFFENSES WHICH DEMONSTRATE UP
FITNESS TO BE AN OFFICER. SB
CHOOSE DEFINITION IS QUITE
BROAD. IT INCLUDES UNIFIED TERM
BIAS ON THE BASIS OF HOUSING
STATUS. IT INCLUDES FAILURE TO
INTERCEDE AND EXCESSIVE FORCE.
THE PERMITS POSTED TO FIND ANY
ACT. THE VIOLATES THE LAW AS
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT. I BELIEVE
AT LEAST ONE SANCTIONS SHORT OF
THE CERTIFICATION OR SUSPENSION
ARE NOT AVAILABLE BUT THE
DEFINITION SHOULD BE LIMITED TO
MORE EGREGIOUS ACTS. WHICH
THEMSELVES OF ALL CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS. ABUSE OF AUTHORITY
HER DISHONESTY THIS BILL GOES
WAY BEYOND THAT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE DO NEED A JUST A
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS. BUT WE
ALSO NEED THAT TO BE FAIR. IF
IT'S NOT FAIR. WE'VE WE'VE
BROUGHT DISCREDIT TO THIS
INSTITUTION TO OURSELVES AND WE
SEND A MESSAGE TO OUR OFFICERS.
THAT WE DON'T CARE. SO AS FOR
NOW. MEMBERS IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
RAISING YOUR MICROPHONES PLEASE
DO SO NOW. MR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I AM
HONORED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO TODAY. AND- I JUST WANT
TO OFFER A REFLECTION UPON WHY
WE'RE HERE YOU KNOW THE HISTORY
OF THE THREAD OF HISTORY RUNS
TO THIS CHAMBER. WE WERE ALL A
GREAT MOMENT ARM PERSONAL HER
SHOES WERE RELUCTANT TO IT. BUT
THE THREAT OF HER THREE RUNS TO
OUR DELIBERATIONS HERE. WHEN I
WAS EIGHT. I WAS A WEIRD LITTLE
EIGHT YEAR OLD AND I WROTE A
LETTER TO THE PRESIDENT JOHN F.
KENNEDY. THAT ADVOCATES
TESTIFIES HOW WEIRD I WAS EIGHT
YEARS OLD RIGHT THE PRESIDENT.
VERY IMPORTANT PRESENT ONE OF
HIS COMMENTS ACTUALLY THAT I'VE
ALWAYS BROUGHT WITH ME IN
PUBLIC SERVICE. IS TO GOVERN IS
TO CHOOSE. THAT IS THE GREAT AN
AWFUL RESPONSIBLE TO THE POLLS
ON EACH OF US TO GOVERN IS TO
CHOOSE. THAT IS A HEAVY METAL
THE BARE UNDER OATH OF OFFICE.
AND THE TIME TO WHICH SAYS
EXERCISES SOMETIME BETWEEN AND
SOMETIMES OF GREAT CONSEQUENCE.
WE SIT HERE IN THIS CHAMBER AND
I'VE OFTEN. REFLECTED UPON WHAT
IS THE PIECE OF PAPER THAT
ABRAHAM LINCOLN IS HOLDEN IS
HANDS. I DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW
THIS PAIN IS ONE OF SEVEN THE
ORIGINAL PAINTED AND LYFT
BEFORE HE WAS ASSASSINATED. SO
I SORT OF THINK THE CANDIDATE
FOR ME IS THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION. MIGHT BE TO
GETTYSBURG ADDRESS WAS ONLY A
COUPLE OUTSTANDING PIECES OF
PAPER USUALLY REMEMBERED FOR.
AND OF COURSE AT STANFORD HE
WAS AND A PRESIDENT OF EPIC
DIMENSION IN A TIME OF EPIC
CHALLENGE. AND STEERED A COURSE
TO CHALLENGE US. TO MOVE INTO A
BETTER FUTURE AS A NATION. AND
I SORT OF FEEL THAT IS WHERE WE
COME IN THIS MOMENT. I USE MY
SUMMER BREAK TO ENJOY READING.
I READ WILLIAM SAFIRE'S GREAT
BOOK FREEDOM NINE HUNDRED PAGES
ABOUT ABRAHAM LINCOLN. AND
EVENTS THAT LED TO THE
EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION. AND
MORE RECENTLY I JUST WRAPPED UP
ERNEST J. GAINES IS TREMENDOUS
BOOK A GATHERING OF OLD MEN.
WHICH IS ABOUT. RELATIONS IN
THE SOUTH. IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES I
COMMITTED TO YOUR READING
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE THREAT
OF HISTORY DOES RUN THROUGH
THIS CHAMBERS. I THINK IT IS
OUR MENTAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
CHOOSE. AND I ACTUALLY FEEL WE
ARE AT A MOMENT WHEN. WE NEED A
MODEL. CHOOSING A BETTER FUTURE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THAT IS WHAT THE
ALLEGORY ON THE WEST PORTICOS
ALL ABOUT YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
ME SAY THAT AGAIN AND AGAIN THE
WEST PORTICO UP THERE YOU GOT
THAT GRIZZLY BEAR ATTACKING A
GUY ON HORSEBACK. BUT
INDEPENDENT AT THE GRIZZLY BEAR
HAD BEEN SUBDUED BY ATHENA.
REPRESENT GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO
COMMUNITY. TRYING TO SUBDUE
THOSE PAIRS THAT ARISE IN THE
LIVES OF OUR CITIZENS IS OUR
JOB. WE DO IT SIMPLY BY OUR
CHOICE EXERCISE THE GREY METAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO GOVERN IS TO
CHOOSE BUT WE DO WITH PARTNERS.
AND I KNOW THIS IS WHAT MISTER
BRADFORD WITH THE SUPPORT OF
TONI ATKINS AND OTHERS. HAVE
LABOR TOWARDS. I THANK THEM FOR
THEIR LABOR. I WANT TO CHOOSE
HISTORY I'M AND I ON THE S. B.
TO URGE YOU TO JOIN. THANK YOU
MISS COOLEY MR MURATSUCHI. YOU.
ARE RECOGNIZED. YEAH.
COLLEAGUES AS A FORMER STATE
PROSECUTOR. I SUPPORT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I REPRESENT.
COMMUNITIES LIKE TORRANCE.
WHERE WE SUPPORT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. YOU'LL NEVER HEAR
ME TALKING ABOUT DE FUNDING THE
POLICE. BECAUSE. WE SUPPORT.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR PROTECTING OUR
FAMILIES OUR NEIGHBORHOODS OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND SO THIS BILL.
I'VE BEEN ANGST THING OVER THIS
BILL FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
BECAUSE. SEVERAL PEOPLE HAVE
SAID THIS ALREADY WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT. THAT WE
NEED A PROCESS TO GET RID OF
BAD COPS. WE NEED. TO GET RID
OF THE PROCESSING TO GET RID OF
BAD COPS A BOOK WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE. AS OUR CALLING FROM
LANCASTER ONE OF THE FEW CAREER
LAW ENFORCEMENT. FOLKS ON THIS
FLOOR STATED THAT IT NEEDS TO
BE FAIR IT NEEDS TO BE FAIR
FOR. ALL OF OUR- MEN AND WOMEN
WHO SERVE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OTHERWISE IT'S NOT FAIR FOR
THEM. MY REVIEW OF THIS. BILL
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE AMENDMENTS.%
THERE ARE CONTINUE TO BE A LOT
OF FAULTS WITH THIS BILL I
GUESS I CONTINUE TO SHARE THE
CONCERNS ABOUT. THE BIASED
NATURE OF THE ADVISORY BOARD.
AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT. BUT AFTER REVIEWING WHAT
I UNDERSTAND TO BE. THE
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF REVIEW THAT
IS PROVIDED IN SB TWO. THE
FIRST DAYS. THAT POST.
DETERMINES WHETHER A COMPLAINT-
REPORT OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT
WARRANTS FURTHER INVESTIGATION
TO DETERMINE WHETHER AN OFFICER
ENGAGED IN SERIOUSNESS
MISCONDUCT. THE SECOND PHASE
THE POST HAS AN INVESTIGATIVE
DIVISION. DIGITAL INVESTIGATION
AND IF NECESSARY CONDUCT
FURTHER INVESTIGATION AND IF
ONLY AND ONLY IF THE POST
DIVISION DETERMINES THAT THERE
IS REASONABLE GROUNDS FOR
DECERTIFICATION BENNETT THEN
BRING THE CASE THE ADVISORY
BOARD. THE ADVISORY BOARD THEN
GET THE CHANCE TO LOOK AT WHAT
THE INVESTIGATIVE THE DIVISION
PRESENTS TO THEM. AND DATE MAKE
THEIR RECOMMENDATION. TO THE
FULL POST COMMISSION. THE FULL
POST COMMISSION. OF TWELVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS OUT OF
SEVENTEEN MEMBERS REVIEWS THE
POST INVESTIGATION. AND THE
BOARD'S RECOMMENDATION AND
DECIDES WHETHER TO ADOPT OR
REJECT IT. IT'S ALSO MY
UNDERSTANDING. THAT THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS. PROVIDES THE
OPTIONS NOT ONLY OF
DECERTIFYING THE OFFICERS BUT
ALSO OF SUSPENDING THE
CERTIFICATION WHICH ABSOLUTELY
MAKES SENSE TO ME. THAT THERE
SHOULD BE DEGREES. OF
DISCIPLINE IT SHOULD NOT BE AN
ALL OR NOTHING PROPOSITION. IF
THE FULL POST COMMISSION
DECIDES TO SEEK DISCIPLINE. THE
OFFICER IS STILL ENTITLED TO A
FULL AND FORMAL ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING. BEFORE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE ON
WHETHER THE DECERTIFICATION IS
WARRANTED. AND F. AFTER THAT IF
THE OFFICER IS STILL NOT
SATISFIED. THEY STILL HAVE THE
RIGHT TO AN APPEAL OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE. HEARING'S
DECISION AND SUPERIOR COURT
THIRTY SECONDS SO. THIS IS NOT
A PERFECT BILL I WISH THE
AUTHOR WOULD HAVE TAKEN MORE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS A FAIR PROCESS. BUT I
DO BELIEVE. THAT WE CANNOT
CONTINUE WITH BUSINESS AS USUAL
I DO BELIEVE THAT THERE BEEN
TOO MANY INCIDENTS OF POLICE
MISCONDUCT AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE
SOMETHING TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE
STOP. SERIOUS MISCONDUCT BY THE
A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER SO
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
SEPARATE THE GOOD COPS FROM THE
BAD COPS. AND FOR THAT REASON I
WILL BE VOTING IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO. MR LOW. MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
ALL RIGHTS IS HERE AND
OBSERVATION EXPERIENCE AS MANY
OF YOU MAY KNOW THAT. I ALSO
COME FROM A FAMILY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS MADE NO I LIVE
WITH MY BROTHER BACK IN THE
DISTRICT. AND HE'S BEEN A
POLICE OFFICER IN OAKLAND AND
CURRENTLY SERVING IN SAN JOSE.
AND JUST TO SHARE WITH YOU THE
EXPERIENCES IN WHICH HE KNOCKS.
ON MY DOOR. AT THREE O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING FINISHING A SHIFT
WITH PUNCTURE WOUNDS IN HIS
HANDS. ASKING ME HAVE YOU
ABANDONED US. DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
THESE EXPERIENCES DOES THE
MEDIA COVER THE EXPERIENCES OF
WHAT IS LIFE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE ON THE
STREETS PROTECTING ANSWERING
EVERY CALL FOR SERVICE. WHEN
ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS NEED THEM.
THIS IS VERY PERSONAL. AND I
OFTENTIMES WONDER AND RECALL
THE EXPERIENCE AND WHICH FOR
OFFICERS WHEN HE WAS IN OAKLAND
WERE KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
AND NOT BE ABLE TO CONTACT HIM.
WHAT THAT FEELING IS LIKE EACH
AND EVERY DAY FOR MEMBERS WHO
HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES. THEY PUT ON
THE UNIFORM PROUDLY TO STAND UP.
AND SERVE OUR COMMUNITY TO
PROTECT AND SERVE WITH DIGNITY
AND DISTINCTION. AT THE SAME
TIME I'VE ALSO TAKEN THE TIME
TO MEET WITH FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES AN OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS. I FELT THE
PAIN AND AGONY. I'VE LISTENED I
AM ALSO. GOING ON RIDE ALONGS
WITH POLICE OFFICERS I
PARTICIPATED IN SIMULATIONS I
HAVE CONVERSATION WITH AYE
POLICE USED TO UNDERSTAND THE
FUNDAMENTALS AND THE CHALLENGES.
THEY'RE DEALING WITH.
COLLEAGUES MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE BEEN MARCHING
WITH US AS WELL WE'VE SEEN THE
MARCHING WITH US IN BLACK LIVES
MATTER WE SEE IN THE MARCHING
AND STOPPING ASIAN HEY WE
DIDN'T EVEN SEE THE MARCHING
AND GAY PRIDE. EVEN WHEN THEY
ARE. NO LONGER WELCOMES. AND
THE INVITATION IS RESCINDED FOR
THEM NOT TO MARCH IN PRIDE IN
UNIFORM THEY STILL MARCH WITH
US. THAT IS THE TYPE OF
DEDICATION MEMBERS HAVE. I'M OF
THE SAME TIME WE TALK ABOUT
STRENGTHENING. INSTITUTION. AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE WEED OUT.
BAD COPS. AND SO THIS BILL IS
ABOUT STRENGTHENING THE
INSTITUTION. THIS BILL IS A
CONTINUATION TO RECTIFY THE
INJUSTICES OF THE PAST BUT
COLLEAGUES AT THE SAME TIME THE
WORK IS NOT DONE IF WE TRULY
CARE ABOUT REFORMING LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEN WE SHOULD
ADEQUATELY FUND. POST WE SHOULD
ADAM GRIDLEY HELP ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE MORE DIVERSITY. AND
RANK AND FILE. MORE AFTER
AMERICAN ASIAN PROVIDER WOMEN
LGBT POLICE CHIEFS SHERIFFS. TO
REFLECT OUR COMMUNITIES SO LET
US NOT STOP HERE AND THINK THAT
OUR JOB IS DONE. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME LET US ALSO NOT
DEMONIZED BECAUSE THERE IS A-
FEAR. ABOUT THE NOTION ABOUT
FEEDING INTO THIS ABOLISHING
THE POLICE AND THE POLICE ARE
BAD. WHEN IN FACT WE ALL WANT
THE SAME THING SAFE STREETS
SAFE COMMUNITIES THEY ARE JUST
LIKE US. SO LET US REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT NOT ONLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION BUT ALSO
WORKING HARD. TO SAY THAT WE
STAND WITH MULTIPLE COMMUNITIES
AND SAYING. WE STAND WITH YOU
WE WANT TO HELP. ADDRESS THE
INEQUITIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
BUT COLLECTIVELY TOGETHER FOR
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MR LOW THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS COLLEAGUES
I RISE TODAY TO ADD MY VOICE TO
THE SUPPORT FOR SB TWO. THIS
WILL SURPRISE NO ONE SINCE I'VE
BEEN OUTSPOKEN ON THE NEED FOR
THIS LEGISLATION. WE KNOW GREAT
MAJORITY POLICE OFFICERS
FAITHFULLY PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY. UNFORTUNATELY AT THE
SAME TIME A FEW BAD ACTORS
JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC SAFETY. IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF KILLINGS LIKE GEORGE
FLOYD- LIZA MCCAIN. AN OFFICER
WHO STANDS BY WHILE A FOLLOW
OFFICERS SOUGHT TO MEMBER THE
PUBLIC. IS JEOPARDIZING OUR
SAFETY. AN OFFICER WHO LIES
ABOUT THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF A
TRAFFIC STOP OR AN ARREST IS
JEOPARDIZING OUR SAFETY. AN
OFFICER SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
WOMAN UNDER COLOR OF AUTHORITY
IS JEOPARDIZING OUR SAFETY. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OFFICERS
WHO DO ANY OF THESE THINGS ARE
KEPT OUT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS DE
CERTIFICATION DOES ABOUT. IT
HAS A CLEAR AND FAIR REVIEW
PROCESS WITH HALF A DOZEN
LEVELS OF REVIEW. BEFORE AN
ACCUSED OFFICERS DEFERRED THE
CERTIFICATION IS FINAL. AND
THAT IS FAR MORE DUE PROCESS
THAN GEORGE FORD GOT. THAT'S
FAR MORE DO DUE PROCESS. IS TO
FIND CLARK THAT. ESTABLISHING
CONSEQUENCES FOR OFFICIAL
MISDEEDS BY POLICE. SHOULD NOT
BE CHARACTERIZED AS HURTING
PLEASE IT'S JUST THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S STRENGTHENS OUR PUBLIC'S
IT STRENGTHENS OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY SYSTEM THIS THIS
CERTIFICATION BILL WILL DO THAT.
IT IS ANOTHER CALIFORNIA
MILESTONE AND I ASK YOUR VOTE
FOR S. B. LAST YEAR I VOTED FOR
SB TWO. THANK YOU MISS BAKER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS DR WEBER YOU
MAY CLOSE. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THIS ROBUST
DEBATE AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE SPEAKER FOR COMING
AND GIVING HIS SUPPORT IT
REALLY MEANS A LOT TO EVERYONE
WHO HAS FOUGHT SO HARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS BILL IS A
REALITY. I REALLY WANT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP. FIRST
ABOUT THE ADVISORY BOARD. SO
YOU KNOW REMEMBER THE ADVISORY
BOARD TO SEVEN COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES AND TWO MEMBERS
FROM THE LAW ENFORCEMENT. THE
TWO OFFICERS ONE LAWYER. TO
FROM AN ACADEMIC OR NONPROFIT
INSTITUTION. TO FROM COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS INTO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AND SO I
THINK THAT IT IS. UNFAIR OF US
TO ASSUME. THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE BY.
ADDITIONALLY YOU KNOW I WANT
EVERYONE TO REMEMBER THAT THE
POST COMMISSION WHICH IS THE
SUPERMAJORITY OF POLICE
OFFICERS THAT THEY START AND IN
THIS PROCESS THE ADVISORY BOARD
IS JUST THERE TO GIVE ADVICE ON
WHETHER OR NOT SOMEONE SHOULD
BE TO CERTIFIED BASED OFF OF A
PROCESS THAT POST INITIATED AND
POST AT THE END OF THE DAY WILL
DETERMINE IF THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS. THE SECOND THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP REVOLVED AROUND THE
ISSUE OF RETROACTIVE
DECERTIFICATION SO THE
COMMISSION HAS THE ABILITY TO
RETROACTIVELY REVIEW CERTAIN
MISCONDUCT RELATED TO DEADLY
USE OF FORCE. SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
DISHONESTY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THE CERTIFICATION. IF THAT
HAPPENED BEFORE TWENTY TWENTY
AND THAT OFFICER WAS NOT
CHARGED AT THE TIME THAT IT IS
UNLIKELY THAT THERE WILL BE
EVIDENCE TO NOW DECERTIFY THAT
OFFICER BUT SHE WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE THE MAJORITY OF THE
COMMISSION DECIDED THAT THEY
WANTED TO REVIEW THAT FILE.
AFTER REVIEWING THE FILE. ONCE
AGAIN NOT PROCESS START THAT
POST WOULD SAY THAT THERE IS
ENOUGH EVIDENCE. TO THEN GO
DOWN THAT SIX STAGE PROCESS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE WENT THROUGH.
SO NOT JUST ANYBODY TWENTY
THIRTY YEARS LATER CAN HAVE
THEIR FILES REVIEW. AND FINALLY
THE ISSUE OF MISCONDUCT AND HOW
TO DEFINE IT. ONCE AGAIN POST
IS DEFINING WHAT MISCONDUCT IS.
NOT NECESSARILY WRITTEN IN
STONE BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS PUTTING OUT
THERE FOR THEIR DEFINITION OF
WHAT BAY DEFINE AS MUCH CONTACT.
SO IN CLOSING I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHORS ALL THE CO AUTHORS
THE SPONSORS AND ALL OF THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS WHO
WORK SO HARD ON THIS BILL. THE
TIME IS NOW TO ESTABLISH A
STATE WIDE PROCESS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY TO BRING
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH FORTY
OTHER THE FORTY SIX OTHER
STATES. TO RESTORE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE BADGE AND
COMMUNITY TRUST I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB TWO
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE ABOUT EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MS REYES YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR EMOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN THE
ONE DAY WAITING PERIOD FOR
CONFERENCES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN TO TAKE
UP ITEM EIGHT AB THIRTY SEVEN
FOR CONCURRENCE TODAY. MR FLOOR
FOR PURPOSE SIR WE WITHHOLD HIS
CONSENT AS A ROLL CALL VOTE
MISTER FLOOR IS WITHHOLDING. MS
REYES MOVES AND MISTER CHOW
SECONDS ON THE ROLE SUSPENSION
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE. CLERK WILL OFFER THE ROLE.
THIS RACE IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MR FLORA IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE. MS REYES IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER FLORA
NOBLE. WELL CLOSER ALL EYES
FIFTY THREE NO SIXTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
COLLEAGUES
WILL MOVE TO TAKE UP ITEM EIGHT
AB THIRTY SEVEN CORPOREAL
ASSIGNABLE THIRTY SEVEN BY
SUMMER BERMAN AND OTHERS AND
ACCORDING TO HIS ELECTIONS.
LISBURN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
SB THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS BACK
FOR CAN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS SET
MINIMUM VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
DROP OFF LOCATION REQUIREMENTS
GIVING VOTERS CONVENIENT OPTION
FOR RETURNING THEIR BALLOTS.
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN SENIOR MEMBERS WISH TO
DEBATE OR DISCUSS ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. TIRED OF
THOSE. ALL THOSE THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. PURPLE CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE
AYES FIFTY SIX KNOWS FIFTEEN
SENTIMENTS ARE ENCOURAGED HIM.
MISS REYES YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
NINETY TO ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE
UP LATE AMENDMENTS ON THE
FOLLOWING BILLS. ITEM NINETY
ONE SB THREE NINE SIX DOLLARS
BY MAYES ITEM ONE SEVENTY THREE
SB EIGHT OH SIX ROTH BY LOW.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. WHEN I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
NINETY TWO ALLOWS SOMEONE
MEMBER GONZALEZ TO TAKE UP LATE
AMENDMENTS O ITEM ONE TWENTY
FIVE SB SIXTY TWO. VERIZON. THE
FOR WITHHOLDING ASK IT'S ENOUGH
FOR LOCAL. HEY MEMBERS- THIS IS
OUR MOTION REQUIRES FORTY VOTES
IS NOT AVAILABLE FOR WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL THE NEWS I REVOKE.
GLOBAL ROLE TELEVOTES HIGHS
FIFTY FIVE NEWS FIFTEEN MOTION
IS SUSPENDED. THIS PRESS AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM NINETY TWO SB
FOURTEEN LAYER TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. HELLO AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR I'M GIVING A ONE DAY
NOTICE TO REMOVE ITEMS EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR SB EIGHT SIXTEEN
SENATE EO COMMITTEE FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE. WHEN THEY
NOTICED THE CLERK WILL KNOW. AT
THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT REVERSE PLEASE MOVE ITEM
ONE THIRTY THREE SB TWO TWENTY
TWO DODD TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
CORBULO AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT. THAT IS
ALL.
HELLO. FOR IS THERE ANY
MEMBER WHO WOULD OBJECT TO
GRANTING RECONSIDERATION TO
AMENDMENTS ON ITEM. FORTY TWO.
FIFTEEN NON IMPRINTED. OKAY
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO SB FIVE TEN
PART WILL READ. FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS. SEVEN FIVE TEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. CINEMATOGRAPHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS OF THE DEATH REMOVE
THE YEARS TO CLAUSE CURRENTLY
IN SB TEN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. MR FOR WE OBJECT TO
HAVE THE AMENDMENTS ARE NATURAL
CALL THE- THANK YOU ARTICLE
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL THE FIRE TO
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS. ALL
THOSE FOLKS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FIFTY ONE
NO SEVENTEEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL WITHOUT THE
PRINTER BACK ON FILE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE SB SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR CLERK WILL READ.
CENTRAL SEVEN SEVEN FORUMS BY
SUMMER STONE. THE SYSTEM YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AMENDMENTS JUST CHANGE
CODE SECTIONS I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AMENDMENTS. YOUR WE
REJECTED THE MEMBERS THAT'S A
ROLL CALL VOTE THANK YOU THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
THE- FIRE TO VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES I FIFTY FOUR NO SIXTEEN
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK
ON FINAL MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE SB SIX NINETY FOUR
FOR PURPOSES OF THE MENACE
CORKERY. SENTINEL SIX NINETY
FOUR OF THE MINUTES BY SOME
MEMBER HOLDEN. REMEMBER HOLDEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SP SIX NINETY
FOUR THAT MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES IN A DRESS CHAPTER IN
ISSUES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. SEEING NO OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ON THE
MEASURE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE ALL THOSE OPPOSING NAME
GUYS HAVE AT THE MOMENT THIRD
OPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM NINETY ONE SB. THREE
NINETY SIX PURPOSES AMENDMENTS
FOR COREY. SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY SIX IN THE MEMBERS BY
SUMMER MEMORIES. SUMMER MEZA
EVEN OPEN FOR AMENDMENTS I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER RIGHTS
PRESENT A MAMMOTH SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY SIX BY SENATOR
DOLLY THESE AMENDMENTS REFLECT
HOW TO TECHNICAL CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN THE SENATE SOMEONE
ADMINISTRATION. RESPECT LASSEN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THE
PERSON NAME. THE EYES HAVE IT
THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED. THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE. NEXT WE'LL MOVE THE
FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR SB SIX
THIRTY SEVEN PURPOSES
AMENDMENTS FOR KOREAN. CINEMA
SIX THIRTY SEVEN MINUTES BY
SOME INFORMATION SOME REMAIN
TRYING TO BE OPEN PAYMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN
FOR AMENDMENTS RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. MR FOR. I
WILL JUMP TO THE MOON SEVERAL
CALL THE- THANK YOU MISTER FOR.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ON THE AMENDMENTS.
YEAH. LOCAL ROLAND HALLIBURTON
I FIFTY THREE KNOWS FIFTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO A FILE
ITEM ONE OH EIGHT SB SEVEN OH
TWO. FOR PERSONAL MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL SEVEN A TWO AND A
MEMBERS BY SUMMER CREA. NEVER
CREATE ANY OPEN FOR YOUR
MINUTES THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS THAT AMENDMENTS TO
SEVEN OH TO OUR TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MITHRIL
MISTER FOR WE OBJECT TO THE
MEMO'S ASTERISK ALTHOUGH THANK
YOU THE CLIP WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON THE
AMENDMENT ALL THOSE THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES AYE AYES FIFTY SIX KNOWS
TWELVE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. NEXT
FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE SB SEVEN
FIFTEEN FOR PURPOSES OF A
MAMMOTH CORPORATION. SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTEEN WITHIN
MINUTES BY SUMMER MCCARTY.
MISTER PARTY MAY OPEN FOR YOUR
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THESE AMENDMENTS ON
BEHALF OF CENTER PORTANTINO OUR
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP MEASURES
FOCUS ON DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE-
THIS WILL REMOVE A SECTION OF
THE BILL AND GIFTING- AS
SUGGESTED BY DOJ AND THE FBI
THEY WILL ALSO ADDRESS SOME
CHAPTER RING OUT. ISSUES FOR
THESE REASONS ASPIRIN AYE BUT
THINKING THANK YOU MR MCCARTY
WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE
VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. FOR WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING CALIBER I FIFTY ONE
KNOWS ELEVEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE WILL
MOVED ITEM ONE THIRTEEN SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO FOR PURPOSES OF
THEM IT'S CORPORATION. SENATE
WILSON FORTY SEVEN MINUTES BY
THE MEMBER OF OUR CAN SIMMER
BACKING ME OPEN FOR YOUR
MINUTES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TAKE AMENDMENTS
TO SB SEVEN FORTY TO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING THEY ALSO ADDRESS
FIRST AMENDMENT CONCERNS. AND
LASTLY THEY CLARIFY LAWFUL
PICKETING ARISING OUT OF A
LABOR DISPUTE IS EXEMPT FROM
THE BELL RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'LL GO TO THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS MARTINEZ THE
FLOOR. YOUR JOB TO THE MINUTES
AFTER ROLL CALL THE- THANK YOU
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON
THE AMENDMENT ALL THOSE FOLKS
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. PARK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I
FIFTY THREE KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE NEXT WE'LL MOVE FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY FIVE SB SIXTY TWO
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SIXTY TWO WITH MMS BY SOME
MEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ THE
RESULTS IN THE OPEN ON YOUR
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU THESE ARE
GOOD PARENTS ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER FLOOR.
WE OBJECT TO THE MEMO'S ASTRAL
CALL VOTE. THANK YOU THE PARK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO
AMENDMENTS. FOR FULL ROLLING
CALENDAR BOTH EYES FIFTY TWO NO
SIXTEEN B. AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE NEXT
WE'LL MOVE THE FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY FIVE SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
FIVE EIGHT SIX FOR THE MOMENT
MY SEMI REGULAR WEBER SINCE
DOCTOR WHATEVER YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THESE
AMENDMENTS FIXATE TRACKING
ERROR MADE BY LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL TO SB TO ACT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU DR WEBER MISTER FLOOR. WE
OBJECT TO THE MEMO'S ESCAROLE
CALL THEM THANK YOU THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE BOTH
EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS THIRTEEN.
I FORTY NINERS THIRTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT TO PRINT BACK ON FILE
NEXT FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SB SIX
NINETEEN FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE WAS SIX NINETEEN
ANONYMOUS BY SUMMER EDUARDO
GARCIA IS A MEMBER GARCIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
AMENDMENTS HE WAS SPEAKING
COLLEAGUES SB SIX NINETEEN-
THESE MEMBERS REMOVE SECTION TO
THE BILL. ALSO REMOVES
OPPOSITION FROM L. A. COUNTY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU MR GARCIA- IS FOR WE
OBJECTED MEMBERS AS A ROLL CALL
VOTE THANK YOU TO CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ON. ALL THOSE
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTES
HIGHS FIFTY TWO KNOWS THIRTEEN
BE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE. NEXT WE'LL MOVE FILE ITEM
ONE SEVEN THREE SB EIGHT OH SIX
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE LATER
SIX OF THE MEMBERS BY SOME
MEMBER LOW. SOME REAL LOW YOU
MAY OPEN FOR YOUR NEEDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THE PERSON NAME
YOU GUYS HAVE IT THE MINISTER
DR THE BILL'S ALFRETON BACK ON
FILE. MEMBERS I AM ORDERING THE
TEST TO REMAIN OPEN TO PROCESS
BUDGET RELATED MATTERS THIS
WEEKEND.
MEMBERS AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING UPON A GERMAN THE
SESSION TODAY ROOM FOR THIRTY
SEVEN FOR TRAVEL CONTACT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY SEPTEMBER SEVENTH FLOOR
SESSION AS OF ONE PM. IN THE
ABSENCE OF ANY OBJECTION THE
PORTHOLES LIFTED WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFFER FOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
ORTEGA CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. WE ARE TO GERMAN TO
MEMORY. YEAH. YEAH IN ORDER.
WHERE THE GERMANS THE MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON THE GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MS RADIUS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO GERMAN IN
THE MEMORY OF A LOCAL HERO FROM
A FAMILY OF HEROES RAYMOND
ORTIZ DRAMATIS. AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY TWO HE WAS DRAFTED INTO
THE ARMY I WAS SENT TO FIGHT IN
THE KOREAN WAR. FOR HIS SERVICE
IN COMBAT HE RECEIVED TWO
BRONZE STARS. UNITED NATIONS
SERVICE MEDAL. COMBAT INFANTRY
BADGE AND A NATIONAL DEFENSE
SERVICE MEDAL. RAYMOND WAS BORN
ON MARCH FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY IN ST BERNARD DINO. I
GREW UP IN FALL IN COLTON I'M
SORRY GREW UP IN BLOOMINGTON
AND WENT TO COLTON HIGH SCHOOL.
HIS PARENTS FRANCISCO AND ON
GOING OUT ON ME THIS. NO TO ME
AS THE- PONCHO AT THE AT THE
ANYA IMMIGRATED FROM JALISCO
MEXICO AND SETTLED IN
BLOOMINGTON. WE SHARE A FAMILY
HISTORY OF HIS FATHER AND MY
GRANDMOTHER WERE COUSINS. IN
FACT HIS PARENTS YOU'RE A BUNCH
OF THE OTHER ONE YEAH WELCOME
TO MY GRANDPARENTS WITH THEIR
TO SIX CHILDREN INTO THEIR HOME
WHEN THEY CAME HERE FROM MEXICO.
AND IT WAS STILL BONTA ON THE
ADORNO WHO WORK WITH MY MOTHER
MY SIBLINGS ARE MYSELF. AS WE
WORKED IN THE FIELDS PICKING
ONIONS AND GRAPES. WE LOST
CONTACT WITH THE FAMILY FOR
DECADES UNTIL RECENTLY WHEN
RAYMOND SOFT VETERANS BENEFITS
BENEFITS. UNBEKNOWNST TO ME HAD
COLLECTED ALL OF MY CAMPAIGN
LITERATURE AND WE CHERISH
BRAGGING THAT I WAS HIS NIECE.
WHEN THE VETERAN
REPRESENTATIVES SAW THE
LITERATURE. MY FRIEND CALLED ME.
WITHIN DAYS WE SCHEDULE THE
MINI FAMILY REUNION AND PLAN TO
MEET AGAIN WITH MORE FAMILY.
WHAT A PRIVILEGE IT WAS TO SEE
HIM TO MEET HIS FAMILY. AND IT
WAS A GREATER PRIVILEGE TO KNOW
OF HIS SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY.
HE WAS THE BROTHER OF EIGHT
SIBLINGS HE AND HIS SIX
BROTHERS WERE ALL DRAFTED INTO
THE MILITARY. ALL SERVED WITH
HONOR AND ALL RETURN HOME ALIVE.
AFTER BEING DISCHARGED FROM
ACTIVE DUTY RAYMOND WORK
COMPLETED ANOTHER EIGHT YEARS.
OF SERVICE IN THE ARMY RESERVE.
RAYMOND WAS A FORTY EIGHT YEAR
RESIDENTS OF FONTANA AND WORKED
AS A FOREMAN. AT THE FONTANA
PAPER MILL FOR TWENTY YEARS HE
WAS MARRIED TO OMAR JACK OUT OF
A HUNDRED METERS FOR FORTY FIVE
YEARS UNTIL HER DEATH IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS SON. AMONG THE CROWD OF A
HUNDRED METERS AND DAUGHTER.
IVANKA THIS. I AM REMINDED OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF FAMILY.I AM
REMINDED OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY. AND
MOST IMPORTANT I AM REMINDED OF
THE IMPACT ONE PERSON ONE
FAMILY CAN HAVE ON THE LIFE OF
ANOTHER PERSON AND OTHER FAMILY.
HIS FAMILY'S KINDNESS AND
SUPPORT TO MY GRANDPARENTS OPEN
DOORS AND OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WERE NEVER FORGOTTEN. WE OFFER
AFTER REMEMBER THEM SO WE HAVE
NOT SEEN THEM IN YEARS. AND NOW
TODAY WE REMEMBER RAYMOND OR
DESTROY ME THIS. FOR HIS
SERVICE FOR HIS KINDNESS AND
FOR HIS LOVE OF FAMILY AND
COUNTRY. MEMBERS I ASK THAT
THIS HOUSE ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU AS RAMOS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN
IN THAT WAY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I RISE THIS MORNING
ON BEHALF OF MY HOME TOWN OF
HOLLISTER CALIFORNIA IN HONOR
OF HENRY SOLORIO ONE OF ITS
FORMER MAYORS IN A LOCAL
LATINO- A TRAILBLAZER. AT TEN
YEARS OLD HENRY- HE BEGAN
TRAVELING UP AND DOWN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITH HIS FATHER
AND BROTHER TO WORK IN THE
FIELDS PEAS IN. NIPOMO AND THE
CHARACTERS ALL OF THAT AND THEN
MOVING ON TO HARVEST FIELDS IN
ORCHARDS AND HOLLISTER. AND
FRESNO. EVENTUALLY HENRY CAME
BACK TO HOLLISTER. AND BEGAN
HIS CAREER PUBLIC SERVICE
VOLUNTEERING TO SERVE IN THE
UNITED STATES ARMY. THE SERVICE
OF EIGHTEEN MONTHS WAS SPENT.
AT LACKLAND ARMY AIR FORCE BASE
IN SAN ANTONIO TEXAS AND IN
WHILE WEARING OUR NATION'S
UNIFORM. HE EXPERIENCED THE
SEGREGATION OF THE JIM CROW ERA.
WHICH REQUIRED HIM TO SIT IN
THE COLORED SECTION OF THE
TRAIN FOR PARTS OF HIS TRIPS
BACK AND FORTH. TO SAY
CALIFORNIA. AND THOSE
EXPERIENCES WITHOUT A DOUBT
WERE WHAT INFLUENCED HIM TO
BECOME A LEADER BACK HOME IN
HOLLISTER WHERE HE BECAME A
CHAMPION FOR LATINO FAMILIES
FAMILIES LIKE MY OWN FOR
WORKING IN THE FIELDS IN IN IN
HOPES OF REALIZING THEIR OWN
DREAM. THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
HIS CAREER HENRY'S CAREER LOCAL
POLITICS SPENT NINETEEN YEARS
HE SERVED ON THE HOLLISTER
PLANNING COMMISSION IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES WHO'S NEXT
ELECTED TO THE HOLLISTER CITY
COUNCIL- AND THAT WAS BEFORE I
BECAME MAYOR. AND AS MAYOR
HENRY WAS ONE OF THE FIRST CITY
LEADERS TO ENDORSE A UFW
BOYCOTT. HE WAS ALSO A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE MEXICAN AMERICAN.
THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. AND
WAS AN ACTIVE SUPPORTER OF
LOCAL WOMEN CANDIDATES. HENRY
ENDED HIS CAREER BY BECOMING
THE FIRST LATINO ELECTED TO THE
SAN BENITO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. TRAILING A PATH
FOR MYSELF TO TAKE UP THE SAME
POSITION REPRESENTING THE SAME-
THE DISTRICT THAT HE DID. SOME
DECADES LATER. I AM FOREVER
GRATEFUL THAT I HAD GIANTS LIKE
HENRY. WHO WHO ALWAYS FOUGHT
FOR WHAT WAS RIGHT. AND SERVED
AS AS MENTORS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES YOUNG ACTIVISTS AND
TO OUR LEADERS. HIS WORK HIS.
HIS DEDICATION TO OUR COMMUNITY
LEFT SAN BENITO COUNTY A BETTER
PLACE FOR ALL OF US. MAY WE ALL
HONOR HIS LEGACY BY NOT
FORGETTING THAT THAT THE WORK
WE DO. THE LAWS WE PASS IN THE
FUNDING WE SECURE IT SO THAT
EVERYONE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LIVE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM WITH
THAT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISREAD S. MISTER
GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN. IN MEMORY OF BETTER
OFF ANDREAS OR AFP IS A WOMAN
IN CALIFORNIA. MRS OR BEARS
ARE. A BETTER KNOWN AS MAMA
BATHA PASSED AWAY AT THE HUMBLE
AGE OF SEVENTY THREE YEARS. OLD
DUE TO COMPLICATIONS OF COVERT
NINETEEN. SHE WAS ONE OF SIX
CHILDREN. AND MANY OF HER
SIBLINGS LOOKED UP TO HER. AS A
MOTHER FIGURE. BATTA LAURA
BAEZA WAS BORN IN MEDICAL WHERE
SHE STARTED WORKING AT THE AGE
OF SEVEN YEARS OF AGE. SHE CAME
TO THE UNITED STATES AT A YOUNG
AGE WHERE SHE WORKED MANY JOBS.
AND INVESTED TWENTY PLUS YEARS
AT THE FISH CANNERY IN
WILMINGTON CALIFORNIA. HER
WELCOMING SMILE PROVIDED
COMFORT TO ALL. AND HER
DELICIOUS FOOD THAT I CAN
ATTEST WAS ALWAYS ALWAYS PUT A
SMILE ON PEOPLE'S FACE THAT HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
BLESSING TO PARTAKE IN HER
DELICIOUS CUISINE. SHE WAS A
VERY SIMPLE WOMAN. AND VERY
DEVOTED. TO THE WORD OF GOD TO
THE FAITH OF HER GOD. THAT
GUIDED HER EACH AND EVERY DAY
SHE LOVED HER CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN VERY MUCH AND WAS
ALWAYS SO FULL OF LIFE. VETERE
IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND
ALICE DALE. OROPEZA WHO SHE
MARRIED FIFTY THREE YEARS AGO.
HE WAS A LABOR LEADER LABOR
ORGANIZER WHO WORKED SIDE BY
SIDE WITH THE THOUGHT CHAVEZ
AND DELORES WORKED OUT. OFTEN
TIMES BETTER HOSTED DELORES AND
ALSO SAYS THAT AT THEIR HOME IN
DELANO CALIFORNIA. SHE CREATED
MANY BEAUTIFUL MEMORIES WITH
HER FOUR CHILDREN. TWELVE
GRANDCHILDREN AND ONE GREAT
GRANDCHILD SHE LEAVES BEHIND A
LEGACY. OUR FAMILY WHO CHAIR
WHO WHICH PROVED WOULD CHERISH
AND LOVE AND ADORNED HER. SHE
IS REMEMBERED. FOR HER KINDNESS
HER WARM HUGS. AND HER SERVICE
TO OTHERS. I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET HER MANY YEARS AGO HER
GRANDSON. STANDS IN THE OFFICE
IN MY OFFICE AS MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR I AM SO GRATEFUL THAT
THEY THAT HE AND THEIR FAMILY
ALLOW ME. TO BE PART OF THIS
GREAT WOMAN'S LIFE WE PRAY THAT
SHE WILL NOW THE REST IN PEACE
BUT ALSO REST IN POWER. AND WE
THANK YOU MEMBERS ALLOWING US
TO HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY AND WE
THANK YOU FOR ADJOURNING IN
MEMORY OF THIS GREAT WOMAN WHO
WILL BE MISSED BY ALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MUCH GIPSON. AND
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ALL
RIGHTS TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
MERVYN MERV MORRIS. MORE PASSED
AWAY LAST WEEK AT THE AGE OF
ONE HUNDRED AND ONE. WELL MERV
IS BEST KNOWN OUTSIDE OF OUR
REGION IS THE FOUNDER OF
MERVYN'S DEPARTMENT STORES.
HE'S BETTER KNOWN LOCALLY FOR A
SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY. AFTER
GROWING UP IN THE SMALL CENTRAL
VALLEY TOWN OF DELANO. MERVYN
LISTED IN THE ARMY DURING A
ROLL WORLD WAR TWO. AFTER BEING
DISCHARGED AS A CAPTAIN MARVEL
RETURNED TO THE LAND OUT TO
WORK FOR HIS PARENTS LOCAL
RETAIL STORE. HE EVENTUALLY
MOVED TO THE BAY AREA AND AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY NINE MORE
OPEN THE FIRST MERVYN'S
DEPARTMENT STORE IN SAN LORENZO.
FROM THE SAME TIME ON A BLIND
DATE. MERMAID IS FUTURE WIFE OF
SIXTY SIX YEARS ROSLYN ROZ
GRASSMANN GROSSMAN. THEY
MARRIED IN NINETEEN FIFTY AND
WE'RE SOON BLESSED WITH FOUR
CHILDREN DIANNE JEFF AND TWINS
JOHN AND JIM. AS THEIR FAMILY
GREW SO DID THE COMPANY OPENING
MORE DEPARTMENT STORES AND
EVENTUALLY GOING PUBLIC IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. MERVYN'S
WAS EVENTUALLY SOLD TO DAYTON
HUDSON NOW KNOWN AS TARGET. AND
BY THE TIME MERV RETIRED THERE
WERE APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
STORES. MORE STAYED BUSY IN
RETIREMENT SERVING ON THE
BOARDS OF DAYTON HUDSON
CORPORATION ROSS STORES PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY VANS
SHOES IN THE OAKLAND TRIBUNE.
HOWEVER HIS REAL PASSION WAS
PHILANTHROPY AND MORE SPENT
MUCH OF HIS TIME SERVING ON
NONPROFIT BOARDS INCLUDING THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUBS OF AMERICA
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES THE PALO ALTO MEDICAL
FOUNDATION STANFORD HOSPITAL.
THE JEWISH HOME FOR THE AGED
MOUNT ZION HOSPITAL SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. FIGHT ON.
IN TWO THOUSAND TUMOR WAS
APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT GEORGE
W. BUSH TO SERVE AS A TRUSTEE
OF THE UNITED STATES HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL MUSEUM. AND HE WAS
ALSO A CIVILIAN ADVISER TO THE
COMMANDING GENERAL OF THE ARMY
AND AIR FORCE EXCHANGE SERVICE.
CLOSER TO HOME. MERV AND HIS
WIFE ROZ MADE A MAJOR
INVESTMENT TO BOTH THE MERVYN
G. MORRIS CLUBHOUSE. FOR THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUBS OF THE
PENINSULA OTHERWISE KNOWN AS B.
G. C. P. THEY'RE ALSO COMMITTED
SUPPORTERS OF THE PENINSULA
VOLUNTEERS IN MENLO PARK.
PROVIDING CRITICAL FUNDS TO
BUILD THE ROSLYN G. MORRIS
ACTIVITY CENTER. B. G. C. P.
WAS MY NONPROFIT OF THE YEAR
LAST YEAR AND SERVES AS A VITAL
RESOURCE FOR SO MANY IN MY
DISTRICT. MURMUR THE HUGE ALLY
FOR THE ORGANIZATION SUPPORTING
THEM WITH HIS TIME HIS
RESOURCES AND ITS CONNECTIONS
TO OTHERS. MARCUS PRESLEY
STEPPED UP DURING THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT FINANCIAL CRISIS
THE HELP THE ORGANIZATION STAY
AFLOAT AND KEEP RUNNING
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY WHEN THE COMMUNITY
NEEDED IT MOST. I WON WITH THE
STORY THE PRESIDENT OF THE G.
C. P. PETER FORTIN BAUGH SHARED
EARLIER THIS WEEK ABOUT A BOARD
MEETING FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
AND I QUOTE. WE WERE HEADING
DOWN A PATH OF BEING CONSCIOUS
AND CUTTING SOME PROGRAMS TO
REDUCE OUR BUDGET. MERV WOULD
BEEN LISTENING QUIETLY THEN
SPOKE UP AND SAID THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HIS KIDS WHO WERE
LIVING IN HIS TOWN AND WE'RE
NOT CUTTING SERVICES TO THEM ON
HIS WATCH. THIS IS INSTANTLY
SUMMARIZED TO THE LEGENDARY
QUOTE OUR KIDS OUR TOWN OUR
WATCH. NO MESSAGES EVER BEEN
DELIVER MORE CONCISELY AND
PRECISELY. WE HELD OUR COURSE
AND THE REST IS HISTORY. I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO ADJOURN THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
MEMORY OF MARVIN MARC MORRIS.
THANK YOU MR BERMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING OR FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MISTER
NAZARIAN MOVES AND MISTER
MURATSUCHI SECONDS. THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
TUESDAY SEPTEMBER SEVENTH AT
ONE PM. WE ARE JOB.